vous aviez moreau merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors on croyait
la décision prise finalement donald
trump pourrait revenir dessus soit
berlin paye soit des soldats américains
partis d'allemagne vous en pensez quoi
de cette menace
je pense que c'est assez intéressant
parce que ça pose la question à quoi
sert le temps et il est assez étonnant
de voir donald trump qui dit que en fait
les troupes américaines sont en
allemagne pour protéger l'allemagne mais
protéger la mc2 quoi la menace
principale qui pèsent sur l'allemagne
est la même qui pèse sur la france et le
terrorisme donc et c'est pas une
organisation militaire comme l'otan qui
va pouvoir servir à quelque chose
donc on a d'un côté tout une un discours
qui est tenu par les états unis par
donald trump
donc il faut remettre également dans le
contexte des des élections américaines
donc tout
toute cette manière d'en faire d'en
faire des tonnes pour finalement pas
grand chose est aussi est aussi à
souligner mais surtout ça pose la
question de encore une fois à quoi sert
le temps et où on est redéployé ses
trois ses troupes qui sont partiellement
retiré allemagne parce qu'il faut
vraiment rappeler que même après ce
retrait s'il a lieu il y aura toujours
25 mille soldats américains en allemagne
et aujourd'hui finalement qu'il apparaît
dans la politique américaine c'est de
vouloir déployer ses troupes et le long
de ce qu'on appelait à
l'entre-deux-guerres la berrière de
l'ess c'est à dire une ligne qui va de
la pologne jusqu'à jusqu'à la roumanie
et à la bulgarie pour essayer de
contenir alors à l'époque c'était pour
contenir l'allemagne aujourd'hui c'est
pour contenir la russie mais comme si la
russie avait l'intention d'envahir les
pays baltes ou la pologne
donc en fait c'est pas mon avis
davantage une crise de l'organisation du
traité de l'atlantique nord
plus qu'une crise de la présence
américaine en allemagne
parmi eux la russie le pentagone a
évoqué également une opération de
dissuasion vis-à-vis de la russie donald
trump a également écrit dans un tweet 1
je le cite l'allemagne achète à la
russie de l'énergie pour des milliards
de dollars chaque année et les états
unis sont censés protéger l'allemagne de
la russie
comment vous
interpréter cette déclaration du
président américain je crois que c'est
la vérité est là en fait c'est que
désormais pour washington berlin est
davantage
un adversaire est un concurrent qu'un
allié parce que en quelque sorte
l'allemagne est une anti amérique c'est
un pays bien géré et très industrialisé
qui a réussi à maintenir un outil
industriel très performant en jouant sur
la haute technologie sur la qualité de
la production et à côté de ça vous avez
au contraire une production américaine
notamment dans le domaine militaro
industriel qui est qui est très
important je rappelle d'ailleurs que les
les canons des chars américains sont
fabriqués par à une métal en allemagne
donc le complexe militaro industriel
allemand est aussi utile à la aux états
unis et bien aujourd'hui washington
voilà elle même comme un concurrent et
notamment concurrents industriel et dans
la spirale de sanctions et de menaces
que l'amérique fait peser non seulement
sur ses adversaires mais même maintenant
sur ses alliés et bien finalement c'est
là dans cette spirale que s'inscrit
cette montée en tension de washington
vis-à-vis de berlin et à mon avis les
raisons économiques sont fondamentales
et finalement cela quoi nous assistons
c'est à la fin progressive du monde
d'après 1945 et en soit moi si j'étais
allemand le départ de troupes étrangères
sur mon seul je ne pourrai que que m'en
réjouir
c'est d'ailleurs étonnant que des pays
qui revendiquent leur souveraineté comme
la pologne rêve que d'une chose c'est
d'avoir des troupes étrangères sur leur
sol qu'elles soient américaines
d'ailleurs ou d'une autre nationalité
alors finalement sur l'échiquier
politique quels sont les alliés de
donald trump
écoutez c'est ce que voilà c'est cette
fameuse barrière de l'est donc c'est le
projet jeu politique polonais bon qui
est assez assez immature c'est-à-dire
l'inter mario mme c'est cette bande de
territoire donc qu'ils partiraient
d'entre eux entre les deux maires c'est
à dire entre les trois maires entre la
mer baltique à la mer noire et
et la mer adriatique donc c'est de faire
une espèce de cordon qui sépare l europe
occidentale de la russie dans la mesure
où est effectivement cela grande peur
des géopoliticiens américains et ils
n'ont ils ont dû souvent écrit c'est que
est bien là
berlin moscou et pourquoi pas paris se
mettre d'accord pour réorganiser en
quelque sorte l'espace européen et en
mettant entre justement entre de
l'allemagne et la russie et bien c'est
cette espèce de cordon de puissance
faible mais très très très motivés à la
fois contre la russie contre l allemagne
eh bien ça peut être une solution et
d'ailleurs il faut également souligner
qu'il ya non seulement ce cordon de deux
petites de petite puissance donc qui
vont de la baltique à la mer noire mais
également l'italie
c'est à dire que l'italie qui est déjà
un porte avions américain et bien d'un à
l'épreuve et encore veut a priori
déplacer une partie de sept de ses
troupes vers vers l'italie pour en
france et le rôle encore une fois de pas
de porte avions deux des états unis en
europe
xavier moreau merci d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes directeur
de strates paul merci